[موسيقى]
للاسف الاجابه يا نعم التوقعات هي انت
بسبب الصدمه الخارجيه اللي بنمر بها البنك
المركزي قد يقطر الى يعني تخفيض اخر يعني
لان مصادر الدخل الاجنبيه متاثره سالبا
بما يحدث على بس خلينا برده هنا يعني اوضح
نقطه مهمه جدا مصر ايوه عندها احتياطي ليس
في مرحله الخطر بل على العكس هو لسه مسجل
زياده في اخر يعني قراءه وكمان صادراتنا
من الغاز بترتفع
بشكل ملحوظ ليس ذلك في حسب مصر ايضا قطع
الشوط كبير في الاصلاحات الاقتصاديه
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
اللي كان برده من اصدار الشهادات هو
امتصاص السيوله النقديه حتى تقلل من حده
ارتفاع التضخم وايضا يعني جعل الجنيه اكثر
جاذبيه يعني لجعل الافراد الذين يعني
اجتنزوا الدولار يعني يتخلون عن الدولار
بتحويله للبنوك في البنوك لجنيه وشراء
الشهادات حتى يستفيدوا من العائد المغري
طبعا همم في حركه ايجابيه همم
راينا العديد من الافراد يقومون بشراء
الشهادات مما يعطي اشاره بان الوضع في سوق
الصرف قد يرى بعض التحسن